ah ah yes hello welcome clesia stand by
for orientation now let's see you just a
moment head it a minute here we
[Music]
are
welcome to the end
of the
universe oh don't look so glum nothing
lasts forever you know as science tells
us all those billions upon billions of
stars were bound to burn out someday
what science didn't tell us of course
was that some damnable dark force would
be accelerating the process dragging the
remaining systems screaming into the
void thanks science we to be on the ball
with
that so here we are the end of all
things one star still burning and anyone
anything that's still alive they've
gathered here the last star Solace and
that's where you come in my dear fellows
you're our last hope 25 of the bravest
strongest strangest and still Al livest
battleborn the universe has ever seen a
plus for surviving the end of all things
but now the real challenge
begins before we fit you for battle
you'd probably like to know what you're
in for let's take a look at a recent
Excursion to the Frozen hellscape of
bliss and the five battleborn who led
the
charge first is Thor capable courageous
and quite pissed about the loss of a
home world to the verel you might think
a bow insufficient for a fiery March of
Vengeance and in most cases you'd be
right but this Eldred Ranger is a
different story a painful Story look
just just don't make fun of her bow I'm
speaking from experience Oscar Mike a
UPR clone Soldier left over from the
long forgotten War he outlived his
Brethren through deaf use of his
Armament heavily augmentable assault
rifle air strike capability vicious frag
grenades and a Nifty bit of St cloak
technology I'm sure he may sound like a
lunatic but he's our
lunatic and an effective one Phoebe is
one of the last like consortium's
greatest Engineers next to yours truly
of course she wields an array of Sabers
held Al Loft by Tech of her own design
not as elegant as some of my designs
then again she can teleport and call
down storms of Swords so I tend to keep
my notes to myself much safer that way
where do I start with orendi she's um
well she she has lots of arms that much
is clear she's also one of the fastest
most lethal fighters in Solace utilizing
her incredible speed and burst of
chaotic energy to cut down any that
standing oh seven Hells that's
disgusting moving the hell on Cal Darius
May slice Dice and puree his foes but
don't let the look fool you he's much
more than a sensient blend
his GTX assault frame and jumpack Grant
him incredible mobility in aerial combat
which pairs rather nicely with his
Reckless disregard for his own safety
thanks karius your death wish is
appreciated they're formidable enough on
their own but together these five
battleborn achieved a victory that
delayed the potentially inevitable death
of the last Star by
car of the one uh 6 hours that's well
it's not nothing
eh ah there you are oh apologies for the
hike but trust me you're better off on
foot oh dear the portal suing brace
yourself
no
woo
damn you NOA at least try to fly
straight I'm fine
to oh whatever get to the Supply Depot
and secure the drop point then we can
begin today suicide mission closing that
downable portal before this gets any
worse
[Music]
Target
eliminated
[Music]
loyr Delta Time 1 2 3
done yeah something something uh blood
bake your
AC
death alas no dice on the remote access
but I have located the control console
get those arms out of the way would
you
one would assume that a colossal hole in
the fabric of space itself would be a
clear enough warning to stay the hell
out of my Affairs or was that too subtle
for you
people that Dracula said colossal hole
I'm pleased we could chat before the
bareli tear you limb limb mark my words
that portal will stabilize the verel
will flood the system soless will fall
and there is nothing you can do to stop
it
in oh yes this will
be come
on
on second thought I'd rather just kill
you
now why should the verel have all the
fun take cover
now
everyone
run what's the matter
hello
there
grenade come
on what's wrong you a little too dead to
fight come along
then
all clear everyone still alive Etc
excellent now stand by for your new
companion a heavily modified Sentry I'll
get Nova to a safe distance go on
activate the wolf
[Music]
Sentry wolf unit online startup
diagnostic
weapons online sensors online sens
self-preservation protocols suspiciously
absent cognitive functions oh he's fine
notice the handsome doomsday device I've
mounted on the back that will provide
the sufficient levels of KaBoom we need
to collapse the verel breach for good if
we can get it there in one piece Mr I
was born combat
knock knock fellas I'm dumb as hell and
thirsty for
death ah you see he's more than capable
of defending himself now get him to the
portal why a shot C empowering that
force field can't be far away F
destroyed but keep an eye on the
cryy go
on are you quite sure about
this
[Music]
the field is down press
onward
feel
power
[Music]
a
F not
me oh guys
yeah
[Music]
oh
fool
[Music]
sure
time
that right there is a big computer these
Security encryptions will take some time
to have that's a door you're talking
about a door you blasted thing engaging
hacking
laser ah well whatever works I
suppose
damn loads of feli coming your way keep
them off the
cental what the
[Music]
master hey he's the elast of
your
[Music]
level the hell
up
more of them no it's a
conservator they really AR screwing
around
today when
ready so
[Music]
fun
grenade i i
[Music]
h
haha that's it that's how we did it
jolly good no a great victory for all
that still live but before you rush into
battle allow me to introduce a few more
of our crew the gentleman sniper Marquee
de caliber precise deadly and like most
of the AI inhabiting Solus these days
absolutely bat insane wages class
Warfare with his collapsable cane rifle
bindle Bay and robotic owl named Houdini
oh how precious ah WRA the generate
swordsman this handsome vampire is an
absolutely ferocious opponent in close
quarters
combat what's that oh well I've just
been informed that he is not indeed a
vampire thus invalidating all of my
wrath fan fiction oh well the
mountainous and biologically improbable
Montana has a rather impressive pair of
guns as well as a minigun ha muscle
joke oh yes we're all about to die my
apologies let's see here fire bullets
ice bullets something he calls man's
formation universe's deadliest finger
moving on the sheet here says combat
botanist but that hardly summarizes M
what of a stranger members of our crew
this
sentient mushroom person throws knives
fungus and even its own head to heal the
others you see quite altruistic which is
a generally a thing with mushroom people
well I don't know I only know the one
and then there's Boulder the very
incarnation of Rage now in a fun size
Boulder blocks all manner of attack with
his shield deals devastating damage with
his runic Axe and fits easily in most
overhead storage bins always at home on
the battlefield Boulder is yes that's
lovely good for you Boulder ah just wait
until you meet Benedict his feathers
would be so Ru and Isaac such spirit
that one a truly magnificent construct
ah such Wonder it's almost enough to
make an old
man gas oh proximity alarm the verel are
here there's no time to spare quickly
get out there you'll meet the others
later I assure you there'll be plenty of
battles to
come
he